[Musique]
nous sommes dans les couloirs d'une
banque bien connu et oui là aussi les
couples ont de l'imagination samedi à
rennes sans le travail que vous faites
quand même le caraco pour aller voir
question dans l'ascenseur vous faites
ici la terreur
car j'attends d'isabelle
on verra bien ce qu'on pourra faire
il avait rencontré ici
je n'ai rencontré ici oui de temps en
temps je me promène dans les couloirs ça
je m'appelle les enfants ont le gars
sont croisés
[Musique]
je pense que tu écoutes choix
son allure un peu comme ça match on
s'est aussi dit qu on a tous une fois qu
elle ajouté
stimuler aussi
soit on n'y a plus personne donc y
compris l arrêté puis m'a pas
l'ascenseur c'est excitant on a toujours
la 300 là quelqu'un enfin je sais pas si
c'est bon on n'est pas un peu tard
parce que justement c'est ce qui fait un
peu le charme
notre aventure il faut quand même un
signe ans et plus c'est un crayon là
vous y allé à temps we pray jeu
[Musique]